so we are right now it's a Flagler's
house which is now a museum and if you
don't know who Flagler was he was a one
new original founders cofounders of the
Standard Oil Company business partners
with Rockefeller and made his wealth a
lot of money to oil a ton of money and
then he decided to get into the real
estate business built one of the most
prestigious properties in America
possibly in the world called breakers
which is right across the street over
there I'll show it to you in a minute
the local members you can be a member
there I think it's like $10,000 for 45
days and then he built this house on
this side which you see right behind me
looks just like the White House except
maybe even better looking than the White
House here's a moral distort
you know this whole thing they keep
talking about multiple streams of income
you keep hearing people talk about and
people get distracted with the next
career what they want to do let me show
you the side here let's go to the side
to call let's see the side by the water
just want to walk over there real quick
so they can see it so many people try to
be already on the next business before
finalizing their existing business and
it hurts them and so cost him a lot of
money and hey I want to go on hotels I
want on restaurants I want to own a
bunch of real estate all over the world
great
make sure you maximize the one you got
because he definitely did and when he
died his leg he lived 83 years he pretty
much did everything his way and he got
the life that he wanted but he maximized
the first business he built he got to
see where his property sets to kind of
get an idea I want to take you here for
you to see it if you haven't heard of
breakers Hotel go look him up
go look at what the property looks like
it is a mile away from Marla go and
Marla go is a property owned by Donald
Trump
I think the membership is $200,000 you
pay one time in his $14,000 your dues
here's the side of his house mother
that's where he lived that's not a
museum that's where he lived until he
died and his wife died and then it
became a museum
this is out of a sense some front of the
house is the marina it's the water this
is where he lived so before you get a
little bit too much into thinking about
the next seven businesses you want to
own study a story like Flagler and a lot
of other people that created their
wealth off of one industry where they
did for 10 20 30 years then they moved
on to bigger big bigger and better
things or one day people all over the
world are coming here to museum just to
see the house he lived in looks like a
museum that's his house and he built a
golf course right across the street from
his house and right across the street
from the golf course he built he built a
450 bedroom property called breakers
which Vanderbilt a party that
Rockefellers had party that all the
presidents have been at it's pretty
exclusive Morrill the story stay focused
go steal your business to levels such
high levels that creates real wealth for
you I'm not talking just you know 2 3 4
million I'm talking real wealth for you
so then you can do anything else you
want to do that
have a great week everybody